the first artificial intelligence love
song has been created
we've got some of the lyrics here
this is by Lovelace GPT they plugged in
thousands and thousands of love poems
and song lyrics and then they came up
with a song Here Delirious ecstasy
the opening line of which has made some
headlines the line is you're my
biohazard baby
and I thought huh
so it's just a kind of a strange lyric
is this just because the the AI was
glitching I don't know I thought you
know with the sexual Revolution with the
widespread hookup culture with swipe
culture
with skyrocketing rates of venereal
disease you're my biohazard baby
probably is inaccurate summation of a
lot of Modern Love so the AI once again
rather precise here
what does it mean
when we when we plug into Ai and we see
all these weird pictures and poems and
speeches and love songs what is that
does that do anything for us is it just
kind of funny
is it accurate is it not as a totally
off base
you know that I'm skeptical of AI as I
am skeptical of all technology and I do
fear that AI is just getting possessed
by demons sometimes but not all the time
sometimes they're more pedestrian
explanations for things
there's one good thing I'll say about AI
which is that AI
can show you a mirror to yourself and to
your culture because AI is basically
just taking inputs from
this whole big wide web of the internet
and then spitting out uh
an output what whatever whatever that
particular type of art will be based on
those inputs and so the idea that forget
about uh biohazard baby the idea that a
modern love song would be Delirious
ecstasy that's true
that's true that is how we think about
love today
we think about love as crazy and
unreasonable and Delirious we think
about it as a kind of an ecstasy you see
this in all of the various sexual
ideologies that are being pushed now
they're being pushed in the name not of
reasonable love and the con and T loss
and the purpose of love and marriage and
family foundation and love and marriage
Love and Marriage go together like a
horse and carriage this I tell you
brother you can't have one without the
other that's gone now we're told
marriage is a joke there's no point to
it there's no point to sex you don't
need to have babies we should just use
contraception all the time if you do
accidentally get pregnant you should
kill the baby through abortion you
should never engage in any kind of
commitment or lifelong Bond through
marriage no no that's all we need to
redefine marriage we need to redefine
all of these things there's no point
other than pleasure there's no point
other than ecstasy in fact
when it comes to one of those sexual
ideologies that we're not allowed to
talk about on YouTube the the great
defense of it from the people who
promote it who have undergone it they'll
say well I felt a euphoria
after I underwent this procedure or that
I felt a u4 and ecstasy
and this is nothing new exactly in the
old back canals of ancient Greece and
Rome you you see a kind of ecstasy
associated with love in our Christian
civilization for a while we had reigned
that in obviously there was still wacky
stuff going on in the fringes but we had
reigned that in to say no there's
actually a purpose to love and sex and
romance and Affairs and the purpose is
to be married and to stay married and to
have kids and to be fruitful and
multiply and pass on what you believe
your values your beliefs your
institutions your behaviors
your rituals your Traditions all of it
into the Next Generation and as we lose
that
we we lose the Next Generation we lose
the future we're left with nothing but
Delirious irrational ecstasy I read too
deeply into an AI love song I don't
think I did right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles our friends in
Virginia sells sold out of their Dark
Spot Corrector and our listeners have
been begging begging like dogs and their
knees for a restock well I've got great
news just in time for summer it is back
in stock geniuselle's famous Dark Spot
Corrector has not won but three Cutting
Edge ingredients and goes to work fast
to Target sunspots dark spots liver
spots even old discoloration on your
face and hands you can now enjoy the
Summer sun Beach and barbecues without
embarrassing spots geniusell's most
popular package also features their
summer Essentials like the best-selling
Ultra retinol moisturizer with a
powerful retinol alternative for safe
use in the sun you'll be amazed at how
quickly you see results or 100 of your
money back guaranteed go to genucel.com
Knowles right now get your dark spot
corrector in the geniusl most popular
package geniusl.com Knowles right now
save over 70 70
most popular package all orders will
include a mystery luxury gift while
supplies last go to genucel.com Knowles
it's a disturbing poll out right now a
poll says that only 18 of young adults
and 29 of Democrats are extremely proud
to be American
not proud in the you know we have a
whole month Pride you know goeth before
destruction and a holy spirit before a
fall pride in the sense of patriotism
National loyalty affection for your
country an extension of filial piety
that's disturbing fewer than one in five
young adults
consider themselves to be extremely
proud to be American consider themselves
to be that is patriotic
I'm not as disturbed about a declining
number of Democrats being proud to be
American because
leftism is opposed to patriotism leftism
has always been opposed to patriotism
and so as the Democrats become more
liberal and more laughed and they follow
their ideas more and more to their
logical conclusion they're going to be
less patriotic that's just built into it
so I'm not surprised by that at all
that's the way it's going to go
young people don't necessarily have to
be less patriotic and yet they are
becoming less patriotic why is that well
I'm in Hungary right now and I can't
help but think of Victor Orban the Prime
Minister here his speech a couple of
days ago
in Romania in which he was lamenting the
fact that Western values these days are
taken to mean nothing more than what was
it LGBT
and mass migration
and War going to war that's it that's
what's considered to be Western values
these days not Christianity not Duty not
dignity not virtue not the pursuit of
Truth not honor or not any of those
those are all they're out
and unfortunately sorry to say
America has been promoting that America
has been flying that rainbow flag
everywhere America with our liberal
establishment has been denying the
things that made America great we've
been denying
the American tradition even you see the
the new version of Superman Superman no
longer stands for truth justice in the
American way he stands for truth justice
and all that other stuff or truth
justice and I don't know diversity
equity and inclusion or something like
that so that's what the libs have been
promoting and so is it any Wonder
that as the country
becomes more and more a stand-in for bad
stuff
that young people will have less and
less affection for their country
Orban made this great point he said
America not America he said Europe is
going to be Christian or it's just going
to fall apart
the only hope to save Europe and I think
we can expand that to the West is
Christianity
or it's going to fall apart or it's
going to descend into a bunch of rival
factions of different appetites and and
disordered passions and desires and it's
it's going to turn into Anarchy and
Chaos which is what is happening all
around us
it's disturbing to see that number
reflected you don't want to hear it but
the people are telling you something
it's reflecting a real problem and
you're going to see that number continue
to decline if the country continues to
stand for a bunch of nonsense that
people don't want to be associated with
boy what a great clip that was now hold
on
ring that Bell subscribe to the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel
see you next time